former Trump advisor Steve Bannon
produced a film that you directed a
number of years ago so you have an
insight into this guy that a lot of
people you know might be beneficial for
us to hear what's you knew Steve been in
the movie producer yeah and you worked
with him probably somewhat closely did
you like him back then I would say he
exerted the same level of charm that he
does today yeah you know among those I
have one of the things I remember is is
that he it was working for a big bank at
the time and he came and one of the
investors in the film came to Council
Bluffs Iowa to help us make the movie
mm-hmm which consisted of him in a
Brooks Brothers suit in a cornfield and
I wondered why he might be there and
then I that without any need for them we
had to kind of cheerleader looking new
makeup assistants on the call sheet that
as the director of that movie um I had
not called for and yet it was on my very
minimal budget to make this film that
they were being paid and and they
weren't local they were from New York
and and and coincidentally Steve Bannon
had flown in from New York and so I
think that that that that started when I
was in my first sense of him is that he
was you know other than the c-word
charming I think there was you know it
was a crook I think is what I thought
this is what I've watched over the years
I didn't even know when I saw him you
know in his because I don't follow
Breitbart and all that stuff so I didn't
even know it was the same Steve Bannon
until I looked at him closely and
imagined the Steve Bannon I knew but
with where the toxins of the soul so
deteriorate and and
and bloat and weld into this I don't
think you can age like that without
hating people so that's my impression of
them we're the makeup
women wear the makeup women good at
their job today
oh I mean every bit as good as most of
the people in the West Wing of today not
the TV show that TV show yeah yeah yeah
you mean the actual West Wing yeah we
have to think of actual things these
days yeah they want to throw us off
listen Sean we're taping this a little
ahead of when it's gonna air two weeks
so there's a good sign that's right oh
no what I'm saying is it's there's a
good chance that when this airs
everything's gonna be fine and worked
out in this bunch of very good chance
I'm you know your lips to whoever's
listening zere's there we know we I
think it's we will be it's worth
recognizing not being in denial about it
we're we're we're in a time where it
were I think it is important to keep up
the culture so I'm not ashamed to be
here with talented people and with you
all in talking about this stuff
if I were a news anchor I think it'd
rather than reporting I'd pull a fire
alarm yeah every night yeah
and keep doing it until somebody
realized there was a fire yeah yeah
the book Bob honey who just do stuff is
available now and give this a read also
for more information on Shawn's charity
we discussed Haiti a little bit at the
top it's an amazing charity and it
really does make a difference and it's
j/p HRO dot org and please anything you
can give is gonna make a massive
difference Sean Penn honor to talk to
you
[Applause]
you